There are ... many famous food systems, so we thought we could make a simple video
In which we investigate which is scientifically appropriate and already bear fruit.
If we look at the issue from the outside, it will look like a simple equation: it determines your weight by balancing between
The number of calories you enter for your body, and those that burn. By changing you to what you eat or
If you change your activity rate, you can lead that equation towards weight gain or loss,
Which in turn leads us to the first class of those diets:
Calorie compliance system. Some companies like Wet Watchers claim that you can eat whatever you like,
As long as you do not exceed your limit of calories per day. Even getting all your calories from fast food is allowed,
But in terms of health, it is important to keep in mind the nutritional value of foods as well.
If you do not consider this, you are at risk of heart problems, lack of nutrients and other chronic health problems.
The reduction of calorie restriction systems with optimal nutrition or CRON diet in general calorie intake by about 20%
While you continue to take daily nutritional requirements.
For example, instead of eating a full apple, the person who follows this system will only eat crusts. Which contain most nutrients.
If used properly and overly, the limit system can be considered a safe and effective way to lose weight.
Next, a carbohydrate reduction system. Many diets suggest South Beach, Atkins, or Zone Diet
Carbohydrates are the bitter enemy of that lean body that has long dreamed of.
The idea lies behind the belief that when you analyze more carbohydrates and not burn the whole amount, the liver turns them into fat.
But for most healthy and fairly active people, carbohydrates break down and are converted into glucosomal cells to provide them with energy,
Very little of it is what converts to fat.
In response to the excessive amount of glucose, the body uses an insulin to convert glucose into glycogen, which stores in the liver and muscle.
This glycogen can be used later in times of low glucose, to nourish the body.
But the type of carbohydrate you eat is really important - you get it from simple sugars like honey, fruit or sugar
Easily converted to triglycerides or fat rather than converted to complex carbohydrates such as cereals and vegetables in general.
If you keep eating too much, and most calories are simple carbohydrates, they will turn into fat.
Carbohydrate reduction systems impose stringent controls at the beginning, so there are no carbohydrates such as bread or pasta,
Nor sugars of fruit, or even of alcohol.
This may lead to some obvious side effects that include constipation, dryness in the mouth, same unpleasant smell, fatigue, dizziness and nausea.
Studies show that the followers of carbohydrate reduction systems tend to lose weight faster, in the early periods, compared
With those who follow calorie restriction systems, but this is due to loss of water,
Which later comes back in the late stages when you are supposed to eat normally.
In addition, the Atkins diet, for example, encourages the intake of calories from high-fat sources and protein-rich sources,
Which means meat, cheese, cream, butter and ... weight loss?
Sounds great, does not it? But many doctors are worried about taking too much saturated fat -
Those that lead to a 'bad' cholesterol and thus lead to an increased risk of heart disease.
Others claim that these types of diets are dangerous and unhealthy, based on the fact that they support limiting foods
Such as carrots, sweet potatoes, or apples, which in turn provide the body with micronutrients and vitamins.
In contrast, people are required to take supplements, which the body can not absorb as efficiently as vitamins, minerals, and micronutrients in foods in general.
After that, there are also concentrated protein fevers.
The basic principle is that protein-rich foods require more energy to digest, and are not broken by the body as easily as high-carbohydrate foods.
This means you will not feel hungry quickly, and will be more portable
To create a difference in calories (the number of calories burned greater than the number of calories used), compared to the same amount of calories from carbohydrates
The Paleo diet as an example, tells us that 10 thousand years ago, agriculture appeared
The human diet changes from systems that rely on fishing, meat eating, wild fruit, vegetables and walnuts to systems that contain more grains.
As a result, some believe that the human body is not designed to digest such processed foods as grain, dairy, and bread.
Some believe that pills lead to health problems associated with tumors,
But this is far from the truth except in cases of digestive disorders.
Because of the direct method of this system, you may find it easier to follow it, it encourages the absorption of more nutrients.
However, because the Paleo system prevents all grains and legumes, we lose an important dietary fiber source to make our intestines work more gently.
Needless to say, the concentrated protein leads to the production of nitrogen, which means foul gases!
Add to that constipation, which allows digested substances to remain longer in the large intestine to remain decomposed and ...
Yeah. More harmful gases.
Now there is another type of diet that we can call "just stop eating"
Those looking for the phrase "get a sporty body fast" may be tempted to eat cabbage soup only for 7 days,
Or follow the "comprehensive cleansing diet" that allows only to drink salt water in the morning and a mixture of water, maple extract, lemon and red pepper throughout the day,
And slimming tea in the evening.
- But all these systems are very unhealthy. Not only because most of what you lose weight is the weight of water in your body,
But because there are many side effects such as dizziness, fatigue, dryness and nausea.
"Comprehensive Cleansing Diet" can lead to the phenomenon of white tongue, which some claim is the result of toxins leaving for your body,
But in fact, the phenomenon is due to dry throat.
After you go through all this, you will probably gain the weight you lose when you stop following the system.
Then there are of course many crazy systems.
Such as eating cotton balls soaked in soup or juice to give yourself a sense of satiety, which in turn does not provide any nutrients
It can cause intestinal obstruction which may require surgical intervention.
Or what about the beautiful sleeping system where you just sleep ... sleep? You can not eat if you're always asleep!
In fact, most systems that rely on fast and dramatic results have the effect of "yo-yo"
It burns the weight initially but also lowers your metabolism, so your body starts burning fewer calories.
And when you go back to eating again ... you have your former weight to win again and even more!
After pursuing the "Biggest Loser" program for six years - some of whom lost hundreds of Bonnets in 7 months - scientists have noticed something exciting.
Not only did most of the study participants gain weight,
But their rates of change have also changed. One of them is now burning less than the average of a person of 800 calories!
After six years of leaving the program, this shows how those cruel methods of weight loss - despite their success at the time they follow -
Carry a long-term effect on your metabolic rate,
Making it difficult for you to control your weight in the future.
The hard truth is that even with the use of organized diets, 97% of people regain everything they lost and more in 3 years.
If you want to lose weight, it is important to find a system that works with you and keeps you enthusiastic, with simple, successive changes.
Of course, the number on the balance does not determine the health of the person,
Although there is much conflict over this perception. If you or someone you know has trouble eating or losing weight
Visit the description box for this video to find links that will tell you more
Translation: team translate autrjim @